if you like totally love never have I
ever here are five other titles that are
definitely worth checking out on this
week's binge guide from creator Mindy
Kaling by the way watch the Mindy
project if you haven't already this
coming-of-age comedy from Netflix called
never have I ever is about the
complicated life of a modern-day first
generation Indian American teenage girl
it's certified fresh' and fans and
critics are both loving it for the
relatable storylines and young cast so
if you are loved and never have I ever
here's what we think you should watch
next starting with our certified fresh'
pic sex education this Netflix show with
two certified fresh' seasons under its
belt centers around a sex therapist is
socially awkward son who teams up with a
classmate to set up an underground sex
therapy clinic at their high school
genius the critics say this show is a
raucous romp through a group of
teenagers whose sexual misadventures are
so thoughtfully rendered adults could
learn a thing or two from them it'll
take you just over 14 hours to get
through the first 17 episodes but
there's no telling just how long after
those awkward feelings you experience
will last next is our under-the-radar
pick and that is on my block while it's
also a coming-of-age comedy from Netflix
the setting is a little different from
never have I ever
following street savvy friends through
the newness of a high school set in the
rough inner city which is why the
critics call this charming show that's
focused on underrepresented communities
the respite from stylized teen dramas
that you didn't know you needed the
first three fresh seasons of this
half-hour show are fun and easy binge
that will take you about 12 hours in
other words just another long day in
quarantine and the brand new pick for
this week is Netflix's Outer Banks which
came out in mid-april
this one is less coming-of-age and more
thrilling adventure about a group of
teenagers from the wrong side of the
tracks who stumble upon a treasure map
that unearths a long buried secret not
to mention some unforeseen trouble and a
little class warfare thrown in you know
just for fun critics say this
over-the-top melodrama is balanced out
by a strong sense of adventure that's
bound to hook those looking to capture
that summer feeling I feel seen season 1
which is fresh will take you less than
eight hours to get through and might
give you an idea of how not
spend your time this summer next up is
our throwback pic and that is the edge
of seventeen this certified fresh' film
from 2016 is about a high-school junior
played by Hailee Steinfeld who is
already a peak awkwardness when she's
faced with the fact that her all-star
older brother is dating her best friend
oh the horror
critics praised the sharp script and
stay that paired with Steinfeld's
outstandingly performance it makes this
more than just another coming-of-age
drama d at just over an hour and a half
this film is a fun watch and a nice
reminder that your own high school
experience could be or could have been
much worse and finally for this week's
editor's pick we are recommending the to
all the boys I've loved before movies
these teen rom-coms follow a teenage
girl played by Lana Condor whose secret
love letters are exposed and wreak havoc
on her love life which goes from
imaginary to out-of-control in the first
film and becomes just plain hard to
navigate in the second critics say that
relatable characters in charming casts
more than make up for a lack of
surprises while fans of the original
should still find the sequel just as
soon worthy at just over three hours to
get through both certified fresh' films
they'll make you smile but also think
twice about where you've been keeping
all of your love letters all right
friends hopefully this will help guide
you through your next few binge sessions
be sure to check back for more
recommendations and ideas based around
the shows and movies that you're
watching now and love right here on the
Rotten Tomatoes binge Guy
you
[Music]